explosion de joie pour ces classes de
cm1 et cm2 de l'école de la nouvelle
amsterdam à elancourt
ils viennent de terminer premiers de
leur groupe ils se sont préparés toute
l'année pour cette quatrième édition du
challenge robotique à skis robe
ouais je fais tourner à gauche et oem de
la lumière du jour
on a travaillé dur pour fait pour faire
sans les robots on les a bien calibrée
tout s'est très bien déroulé pendant
deux jours mille élèves de la maternelle
à la seconde se sont affrontés sur la
scène du prix sema et long cours
le principe faire évoluer un petit robot
sur un parcours semé d'obstacles thème
retenu cette année robotique et cinéma
pour récolter un maximum de points il
fallait arriver jusqu'au trophée on
trouve ça intéressant parce que ça nous
faisait travailler dans plusieurs
domaines notamment au niveau des
mathématiques mais aussi au niveau du
français sur la rédaction des textes les
mises en scène aussi filmé et beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup dans le repérage dans
l'espace organisé par saint quentin en
yvelines et l'éducation nationale ce
rendez vous annuel permet de mettre en
avant l'enseignement du codage à l'école
80% des emplois demain seront
lié au numérique donc il faut vraiment
amélioré notre culture numérique
l'implication plus des enfants
extraordinaires de vous voyez qu'ils
sont heureux ils sont ils prennent du
plaisir à prendre
chaque année on se rend compte qu'on
n'embarque de plus en plus de classes de
plus en plus d'établissements et les
partenaires sont toujours très réactifs
pour nous accompagner sur ce projet
chaque apprenti codeurs a été récompensé
pour son investissement est d'ici 2020
100 % des écoles de saint quentin en
yvelines pourront être équipés d'outils
numériques